foreign
that sounds awesome hey what's up Ann
and Cheyenne Peter Pan with a plan
what's up Stan
I like your rhymes I'm I'm a I'm a a
rapper too okay I'm actually not I'm not
even close not even close what's up well
we all have to have a uh closet
personality
I have so many Personalities in the
closet for real you have no idea and you
have
none no
no all right so what's up
what so uh I wrote down the question
because I knew I couldn't get through it
otherwise let's do it let's do it okay
um my question is how do I make healthy
Memorial to the past in the midst of
grief well not
stuffing it or giving way to the
busyness of now in preparing for the
future
be more specific
um
and let me say let me say it this way
of course you can't you've lost somebody
right
yeah okay so listen we're going to be
real Direct in this call okay okay and
you've been masterful at managing this
by speaking above it
but we're gonna link arms and we're
gonna walk right through the middle of
it cool
true okay okay
um let's head in
uh well um
I lost my 10 month old
uh two months ago
um to
well uh the one word I hate is
undeterminable in all the reports so I
guess that's it yeah and
um hey hold on stop right there
yeah
I'm so sorry
thank you
what was what was the baby's name
I didn't hear you uh banaya banaya yes
it's very unusual name spell that
d-e-n-a-i-a-h-i-a-h banaya beautiful
and tell me about this little boy was he
a mess
brain damage because of delivery okay a
healthy pregnancy beforehand and just
suddenly something went wrong with the
delivery so he was in the NICU for
um over a month
and the lovely amidst kovid and
all the hospital regulations and that's
a whole other story
and so um
is just
and then we moved and
move States and so it's
it feels like
I I always say that it feels like I was
stolen time from him because he was only
alive for 10 months and
it was it was one thing after the other
the others together so
but um I mean he was making progress and
he was even going to therapy and they
were telling me that the six-month plan
that they had that he might be crawling
and everything and I was so happy and
then the next day I found him cult
laughs
that little boy won the lottery when he
got you as his mom
you did
and Mamas are not supposed to hold
babies and you know that right
I know that
I'm so sorry
it's against the rules it's not supposed
to be that way
foreign
so that was two months ago
yeah okay does it feel like the the
lights are still turned down low and
you're still breathing through fog
okay hey it's right where you need to be
and anybody who tells you otherwise they
did they don't get a vote okay what
about the seven-year-old and those
five-year-olds and the other kids here's
a great gift you can give those kids
could you tell mommy's really sad today
if you don't they're gonna think
whatever's going on in the house is
their fault okay
and so a great gift you can give them is
to say Mommy's thinking about banaya
today I'm very sad
okay yeah
mm-hmm
let them see they will they will see
themselves by the Light of the love you
show for banaya
okay
okay they'll they'll feel the the warmth
and the heat from that you're not taking
something from them you are lighting up
their world with that
okay
have you um sat down and Written banaya
Letter yet
okay you need to do that at some and
there's no rush on it and I would
recommend that you do that with your
family
that everybody draw a picture
and they write they'll write a letter
and you all get together one night and
you'll do that together
it can be to to honor month three it
could be to honor month six but some
sort of private gestials
here's a letter I wrote to banaya
and feel free to put up a stocking to
keep his picture up right
but all that stuff is for tomorrow right
now it's yeah you're going through the
motions man do you have is um Dad around
um because we just moved he's been
pouring himself into work okay he's also
pouring himself into work because that's
an um an anesthetic
I know I know listen
people lose their marriages over this
because they agree people grieve
differently and it causes a wedge
between them
all right
so do you want the um curveball yet are
you pregnant
yes congratulations
because because well I guess why not
hmm
so
what I'm about to say is going to sound
trite and stupid and some idiot's gonna
um
I don't care read the comments yeah
exactly your grief is gonna be it is
very very valuable
it's not good I don't wish it on anybody
but it has deep value
and
celebrating the life of your new baby
will also have deep and profound value
okay
and one doesn't replace the other
that's what I've always feared
it it it won't
but I will always be with you
mm-hmm
you will get a plus one
not a replacement okay okay
and even if you and your husband decided
we want to have another baby right away
and get pregnant right away
that's okay
realize gotcha gotcha so you're five six
months away all along
here we go right
foreign
so you're gonna be nervous and you're
gonna be anxious and you're going to be
wired up and you're going to be freaked
out and all that's normal and good
okay
yeah
do you have a couple of women that you
can that will ride with you through this
um
here um me and most of them are
uh across state lines unfortunately
uh listen I can't I cannot recommend it
enough
have a text thread of women that you
trust
that you can just that call them find
three or four of them and say I'm I'm
specifically picking you
y'all are gonna be my ride or dies
through this pregnancy
I'm gonna text you at midnight and say
I'm freaked out
and I want you just to text me something
back hilarious or text me something back
some silly dumb saying that you got off
Pinterest or whatever I don't care
whatever works for you okay and
let them know they're you're going to be
reaching out to them and I want you to
be crazy slash real real Brave
and I want you to go find a class go
find a support group or something in
your new community of women who've just
lost a kid women who have are
um moms who are fill in the blank but I
want you to go find some real human
beings in your local area that you can
point to and that they can you can see
them and they can see you you cannot go
through this next season alone
mm-hmm
do you promise me you will choose to not
do this thing alone
okay this is for you this is for your
kids this is for banaya this is for this
unborn little baby
okay it's for your husband everybody
um what does your husband think about
having a new kid
oh he's over the moon
I'm the one that can't I'm the one
that's
I thought you just can't connect I mean
all the other kids I could connect even
though I was not expecting them I could
connect with them but
foreign you're searching for feelings
right now
and your bodies have shut the feeling
switches turned them way down
because rightfully so
right
um
that's when we have to lean on what you
just said and I know this gets a bad rap
but going through the motions but we're
going to do the things that we know keep
us well even we don't feel like it
I'm not going to sit there and and
scroll on social media I'm gonna go for
a walk
I want to have seven large pizzas I'm
just gonna have one have one right and
not really but I I want to
oh I would
no no uh Ben and Jerry Knights I mean
I'm not gonna take that from you I'm not
gonna do it I may have one or two though
so I'm not gonna take that for you but
um but again 80 20 right on the whole
we're gonna do things that we know even
we don't feel like it
because with with your what's your
what's your oldest kid's name
so you had this Bond instantly like oh
man I'm doing this for you and we're
going we're going on walks and we're
going for you don't have that right now
and so we're gonna make a list of things
and we're gonna have some people in our
life to help keep me accountable who are
going to check on me today have you
eaten today
something with protein in it
right and I know you're gonna be in the
store looking at the Ben Jerry's things
on the back to see how much proteins in
it hey I get it
oh
[Laughter]
we're gonna do the things that we need
to do
over this next period and
um
I'm gonna tell you something really
really hard okay
wait you haven't no yeah not yet
okay
and
um
I want you to hold your hands together
right now
and I want you to interlock your fingers
okay
but I don't want you to squeeze the crap
out of your hands I just want you to
hold them Loosely for a second okay
and I want you to hear me really closely
the last awful thing you saw
of banaya
the CPR
the yelling and screaming
that picture
you are not keeping him Alive by going
back to those thoughts all the time
please
okay
those thoughts your body will go back to
them because it's trying to protect you
from that ever happening again in the
future that's what it's trying to do
it's trying to help out
and it's making it much much worse
and so what I want you to do
is I want you to think of two or three
or four of your favorite memories of
banaya
the time when that goofy little boy
smiled at you
or he almost
almost crawled a little bitish and you
cheered and then he kind of got startled
whatever those moments are
or your other kids messing around with
him
can I have videos so many videos
when the lightning bolts strike and the
lightning bolts of
your walk past the hall and you look
over and you see that or you may not see
him in the in his crib but you feel it
your body responds as though he's there
I want you to practice what would be the
hardest moment of discipline of your
entire life
is I want you to stop take a deep breath
exhale hard
and picture in your mind intentionally
one of those hilarious fun silly videos
okay and here's what we're gonna do
we're going to consciously over time
teach our body that we remember banaya
we're not remembering the terrifying
scary moments
we're remembering the moments with a
smile on his face
when the house was full of light
and you're not doing a disservice to him
you're not doing a you're not somehow
whitewashing over what happened none of
that you are honoring his memory
by letting his memory reside in you as
light not as the heaviness of what
actually happened does that make sense
yeah and you're never gonna fully let
him go he's part of you it's your family
okay he always will be
you'll get some dope tattoo one day or
something I don't know but don't do that
while you're pregnant that would be
incredible
um needles before sewing and that's
their only function I agree to
disagreement it's cool it's cool
um but
I want you to write him a letter and hey
while you're at it write your new baby a
letter is it a boy or girl have you
found out yet
um girl
I think John uh is a great name just
hashtag we've already
boo
boo hey write her letter too
and let her know you are super jazzed to
see her and you can't wait till you get
to tell her about a little brother that
she had because she never got to meet
him but man he was a character mm-hmm
is that fair
yeah
okay hey
um you're one of the bravest people I'll
talk to
this month
I'm grateful for you for sharing your
story oh do I I don't feel like it I
know
your feelings are all all muted out
right now
but one of my big promises on this show
is I won't lie to you and so I'm I'm
telling you the truth
you're a brave mom who's dealing with
the worst thing that could ever happen
to a mother
foreign
and you're making sure your other kids
are fed
regular kids are warm
and you're making sure that you're okay
because you're now carrying
a new baby
and getting up when we don't want to
heading into the fire every morning
that's bravery
that's you
so grateful for you Anne but now I won
the lottery when he got you
and I know you won the lottery when you
got him